bonjour monsieur le Président du
tribunal judiciaire de Paris madame la
procureur de la République près le
première vice-présidente et monsieur le
procureur adjoint en charge de la
division GES junalco du parquet de Paris
alors on auditionne on vous auditionne
aujourd'hui au format junalco
juridiction nationale de lutte contre la
criminalité organisé je déroule puisque
cette audition est publique et que ceux
qui nous écoutent n'ont pas forcément la
maîtrise de notre de la terminologie qui
est la nôtre je vous remercie très
chaleureusement de votre présence ici en
réponse à
notre invitation convocation devant
cette commission d'enquête sur l'impact
du narcotrafic en France et les mesures
à y prendre pour y remédier que nous
venons d'entamer depuis 2 semaines qui
nous amène jusqu'au début mai pour
traiter de cette question importante
attente pour notre pays dont on mesure
audition après audition les ravages les
dangers et l'ampleur pour entamer nos
nos travaux sous le contrôle du
rapporteur Étienne blanc et des
collègues qui sont présents ce matin je
vais commencer par des formalités qui
tiennent à la nature de cette commission
d'enquête puisque je vous rappelle qu'un
faux témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 434-15 du code pénal et je vais
vous inviter chacune et chacun d'entre
vous à prêter serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité à lever la
main droite et à dire je le jure je jure
je jure je le jure je le jure merci ces
formalités étant accompli je vous
propose peut-être qu'on vous laisse
dérouler un propoliminaire et puis après
vous serez soumis au feu roulant des
questions des sénatrices et sénateurs en
commençant par le rapporteur je vous en
prie merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur sénateur
rapporteur madame la sénatrice messieurs
les sénateurs ma qualité de président de
la juridiction parisienne quelques mots
de présentation euh très très général
sur la spécificité de cette juridiction
et l'articulation avec l'objet de
votre étude et de votre enquête la
juridiction parisienne comme vous le
savez est la première juridiction de
France et par ces caractéristiques voulu
par le législateur nous avons de
nombreuses compétences des compétences
locales des compétences régionales qui
peuvent s'articuler bien évidemment avec
les compétences liées à la JIRS
juridiction interrégionale spécialisée
des compétences également nationales et
des compétences internationale
compétence nationale puisque la
juridiction accueille le siège du
parquet national antiterrorisme le
parquet national financier et nous avons
également dans différents domaines aussi
bien en matière civile qu'en matière
pénale une compétence particulière cela
explique que forcément la juridiction
parisienne dispose d'effectifs ou
d'organisations spécifiques pour
répondre à ses attentes j'insiste sur le
fait également que
euh la justice en général et la justice
parisienne en particulier a la
responsabilité de la portée effective
des lois et règlements c'est-à-dire que
lorsqu'il y a des politiques publiques
qui sont votées par la représentation
nationale voulu par l'exécutif et mis en
œuvre par l'exécutif et bien très
fréquemment de nombreuses enjeux se règl
devant l'institution judiciaire et
celle-ci avec ses caractéristiques et
notamment les principes généraux du
droit que nous devons mettre en œuvre
dans toutes les procédures a à cœur
d'apporter la meilleure réponse possible
avec la ressource dont elle dispose en
matière de lutte contre les stupéfian ce
que je peux dire c'est que bien
évidemment nous avons de nombreux
services qui sont saisis de ces de ces
matières qu'il s'agisse de des services
de droit commun qui gère un grand nombre
de procédures 30 juges d'instruction de
nombreuses chambres correctionnelles des
juges de l'application des peines et des
juges des libertés de la détention qui
sont également très engagés en cette
matière
nous avons la spécificité aussi
d'accueillir madame la procureure
beaucoup mieux que moi la compétence de
la juridiction nationale lutte contre la
cralité organisée la junalco voté et
décidé m en œuvre en 2019 et qui
aujourd'hui fait partie de notre paysage
avec je dirais la volonté de la part de
la juridiction de donner une attention
particulière aux différentes procédures
qui relève de cette matière notamment
avec des juges d'instruction qui sont au
nombre de Neu désormais animé par Madame
alexique qui est à mes côté elle vous
précisera les spécificités de des
enquêtes qui sont menées et qui sont
tous des magistrats expérimentés des
magistrats aguéris sur la coopération
internationale les techniques d'enquête
la procédure pénale en général et qui
porte de très très importantes
procédures nous avons également depuis
un certain nombre d'années une chambre
spécialisée dite la 1633 qui est
composée aujourd'hui de 14 magistrats et
qui a la spécificité de juger les
affaires de terrorisme et les affaires
de criminalité organisée là aussi j'ai à
cœur d'affecter dans cette chambre des
magistrats en nombre suffisant des
magistrats expérimentés des magistrats
très engagés je crois que ce que nous
devons aussi vous dire c'est que nous
avons l'engagement professionnel
d'offrir des compétences particulières
sur ces contentieux extrêmement
sensibles ce que je voudrais bien sûr
dire également c'est que ces affaires
méritent une attention par particulière
et votre commission y participe bien
évidemment et il est important que le
ministère de la justice notamment la
direction des services judiciaires dans
la proximité qu'elle peut avoir avec la
juridiction parisienne notamment les
chefs de juridiction et à cœur avec nous
d'apporter toute la ressource nécessaire
pour bien faire fonctionner ces services
j'insiste sur le fait que cela ne doit
pas exclusivement se traduire par des
magistrats spécialisés engagés en
nombreux suffisant mais aussi les
collaborateurs du autour du juge et
notamment les assistants spécialisés et
à ce titre même si nous pouvons relever
d'importants progrès depuis un certain
nombre d'années il faut le dire nous
pouvons quand même constater à travers
les différents dialogues de gestion que
la juridiction parisienne pourrait
bénéficier d'équipes renforcées
notamment sur tout ce qui concerne
l'approfondissement des enjeux
patrimoniaux fiscau de certains dossiers
qui mériteront certainement les
développements au cours de nos échanges
ce matin et nous avons à cœur avec
Madame Alexie que je DIRIS également
avec Madame la procureur de porter
régulièrement cette spécificité
parisienne dans nos échanges avec le
ministère de la Justice
pour que là aussi la capacité judiciaire
soit la hauteur des enjeux que nous
portons collectivement voilà ce que je
pouvais vous dire de manière très très
générale je crois que vous pouvez
compter sur la juridiction parisienne
pour être au rendez-vous de de ces
procédures qui sont extrêmement lourdes
extrêmement complexes je crois que ça il
faut le voir je pense que vous avez
certainement à travers les différentses
auditions mesurer l'ampleur du phénomène
il y a les délinquences de droit commun
qui relèvent aussi des trafic de
stupéfiants mais et les procédures que
nous avons à instruire et à juger sont
des procédures colossales en nombre de
personnes mises en examen en nombre de
partis civiles dans certaines affaires
aussi relevant de la grande criminalité
organisée et le temps d'audience
nécessaire pour juger ces affaires et il
est vrai que en cette matière il
faudrait que nous soyons plus
performants c'est-à-dire des délais
d'instruction plus courts et des délais
de jugement beaucoup plus court et nous
avons hélas souvent à déplorer le fait
que nous soyons obligés de euh passer
par un temps on va dire de mise en état
de de l'audiencement pénal euh qui
retarde la phase de jugement alors que
dans un monde idéal il serait
souhaitable que lorsque l'affaire est
terminée à l'instruction nous soyons en
capacité de le juger dans un délai très
très court pour être beaucoup plus
efficient en terme de de performance
judiciaire il y a là certainement des
marches de progrès sur lesquel nous
pourrons revenir voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur son êre d'accord de
manière très synthétique en introduction
du propos de la juridiction parisienne
merci de ce cadrage liminaire donc je
laisse monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur madame la sénatrice messieurs
les sénateurs permettez-moi tout d'abord
de vous remercier d'avoir songé à
solliciter les magistrats de la junealco
dans le cadre de vos travaux c'est un
signal fort que la mobilisation de votre
assemblée sur cette thématique à mes
côté se trouve Éric SERFAS qui est donc
procureur adjoint et qui à la tête de la
3e division qui est celle que l'on
appelle au sein du parquet de Paris au
sein de ces six divisions que comporte
parquet de Paris la jirce junalcou c'est
une division qui est composée
aujourd'hui de 22 magistrats il y a
quelques mois ils étaient 17 et si j'ai
choisi de renforcer cette division au
sein de laquelle se trouve la junalco
c'est parce que véritablement l'état de
la menace ne me laissait pas d'autre
choix mais il faut que le j'ai assumé le
fait que le renfort de cette division
apporté à cette division là été au
détriment d'autres sections du parquet
de Paris et pour tout vous dire lorsque
je vous dis 22 je trouve que face à la
menace les effectifs dont je dispose me
paraissent encore bien réduits alors la
junalco le président l'a dit elle a été
crée en 2019 elle a été installé à Paris
véritablement en janvier 2020 ces
critères de saisine résultent d'une note
de juin 2020 note sur laquelle quand je
suis arrivée à Paris fin 2021 je n'ai
pas eu l'idée de venir parce qu'elle m'
paraît tout à fait correspondre à la
volonté de se positionner sur le très
haut niveau du spectre de la très grande
criminalité organisée alors les critères
de
cisine on vous communiquera la note si
vous souhaitez je ne vais pas la
détaillé dans ces dans ces spécificités
mais très clairement c'est s'attaquer au
aux groupes de très grande criminalité
organisée parce qu'ils sont hiérarchisés
parce qu'ils sont structurés parce
qu'ils ont un caractère national ou
transnational parce parce qu'il y a la
sophistication des modes opératoires
parce que les quantités de profils
illicites
généré nous nous interroge parce que
aussi notre volonté est celle de cibler
ce qu'on appelle des cibles de haute
valeur dans tout ce périmètre de la très
grande criminalité organisée alors la
junalcou d'une certaine manière elle
fait figure de petites nouvelles dans la
lutte contre la criminalité organisée au
côté des geirs mais si vous le permettez
en dépit de l' pleur de la menace je CIS
pouvoir affirmer qu'elle avance mais si
elle avance elle a encore besoin
d'autres outils et parmi lesquels des
outils législatifs que je vais proposer
de partager et donc vous l'aurez compris
c'est un peu sur ces trois points que je
vais très rapidement faire mon mes
propos préliminaires j'ai tenté dans ces
propos préliminaires de répondre aux
questions que vous nous avait préadressé
dans la perspective de cette audition
mais bien sûr ça nous empêchera pas les
échanges évidemment alors l'ampleur de
la menace d'autres avant moi que vous
avez auditionné vous l'ont décrite j'ai
assumé dans un dansun propos publique
médiatique une formule que je fais
encore mienne et toujours mienne la
réalité dépasse la
fiction il s'agit pas ici d'une réalité
fantasmée cette affirmation elle repose
sur l'exploitation des données dont la
junalco a pu disposer et grâce je ne
sais pas si c'était un alignement de
planète mais quand même au moment où la
junalco est créée par parèlement les
services de enquêteur infiltre deux
réseaux de téléphonie cryptée dont on
vous a sans doute déjà parlé Sky ECC et
encrochat et finalement d'une certaine
manière quand on pénètre ce réseau de
téléphonie crryté on est dans le salon
des délinquants et on les écoute et ils
ne savent pas qu'ils sont écoutés et
qu'est-ce qu'on constate des trafics de
toute nature on vous l'a dit parmi
lesquels le narcraafique à l'heure
actuelle les dossiers de la junalco ce
sont 137 dossier 71 en criminalité
organisée et 31 dossierers de trafic de
stupéfiants soit 44 %. à l'heure
actuelle les trafics que l'on constate
ce sont les les trafics qui se déploient
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
mais totalement à l'international alors
bien sûr il y a les pays producteurs
bien sûr il y a les pays consommateurs
mais il y a aussi un très fort impact
sur ce que je vais qualifier de pays
rebond c'est-à-dire ces pays qui
constituent du fait de leur
positionnement géographique des pays
tout à fait ciblés pour permettre
l'acheminement des produits par les
ports par les aéroports de toute nature
et parce que le trafic routier est
toujours présent alors il faut le dire
tout de suite et je pense que on va vous
le répéter à l'envie nos services
juridiques même si la coopération
internationale progresse de façon
significative et si la la coopération
européenne est très fluide bien il
constitue quand même pour nous
quelquefois des entraves pour s'adapter
à nos systèmes juridiques différents
pour les délinquants ça peut constituer
tout à fait des leviers et d'ailleurs
peut-être y reviendronsnous une des
grandes difficultés qu'on a à l'heure
actuelle c'est que les hauts niveaux des
trafiquants de stupéfiants les haut
Barou de la drogue comme on pourrait
dire sur cette appellation classique
sont aujourd'hui réfugiés dans un
certain nombre de pays où les processus
d'extradition sont aujourd'hui
interrompus alors junalco pour vous
donner un exemple en mai 2022 c'est
l'interception de 22 tonnes d'un mélange
de cocaïne et de sucre nous sommes au
port du Havre il est parti ce navire est
parti quelques jours plus tôt d'un port
colombien les interpellations qui vont
se réaliser cinq interpellations sur le
territoire région parisiennes quatre
dans la région PACA et parmi ces
personnes interpellées cinq colobiens et
si j'y viens c'est que ces cinq
colombiens sont en fait des chimistes
qui étaient envoyés depuis l'Amérique
latine sur notre territoire pour
procéder à la séparation des produits
donc vous voyez à quel point il y a une
capacité fonctionnelle et opérationnelle
qui sait se déployer sur tous les
niveaux
j'ajouterais que nous avons eu trois
personnes également interpellées en
Espagne une personne arrêtée sur mandat
d'arrêt à Dubaï qui a depuis été libéré
qui continue d'être sous la surveillance
des autorités de paayotte mais qui pour
le moment ne nous a pas été remise pour
les moyens très rapidement encore bon
les moyens des narcotrafiquants je pense
qu'on vous les a dit aussi je me permets
de nous dire notre regard judiciaire et
vous verrez sans doute qu'il correspond
tout à fait au regard des services
enquêteurs des achats de produits par
kilo une capacité d'installer des caches
dans les navires extraordinaires des
modalités de transport qui s'adaptent
constamment le dernier en date il est
tout à fait récent et bien c'est par
voie aérienne qu'on a importé
465 kg de cocaïne qui était dissimulé
dans un
électroaimant donc arrivé sur le
territoire français par voie aérienne
enfin belge d'ailleurs dans un premier
temps puis français et donc je n'ai pas
en l'état actuel du dossier la
connaissance de ce que ça a pu coûter
mais je crois qu'on peut l'imaginer et
ça veut dire qu'on est prêt à dépenser
beaucoup pour introduire toujours et
encore création d'outils dédiés on l'a
vu des messageries crypté encore et
toujours une stratégie de saturation de
nos ports on parle souvent de retardam
et d'enverse mais le HAV Montoir de
Bretagne Marseille c'est la même chose
et puis maintenant ce sont les petits
bateaux de pêche les bateaux de
plaisance les croiséristes les aéroports
on l'a dit et puis des capacités
financières considérables ne sont
révélés notamment par la capacité de
perdre du produit dans la méthode du
dropof on passe le produit d'
embarcation à l'autre il y a des pertes
mais on les assume et je suppose que
vous avez tous en mémoire ces ballots de
cocaïne qui se sont échoué dans le
centin je crois que la quantité totale
qui a été reconstituée c'était 2 tonnes
de et puis ce sont des moyens financiers
qui sont totalement révélés par
l'augmentation des saisies opéré alors
soyons clair je ne suis pas naïve les
saisies opéré augmentent mais ce n'est
rien par rapport au profit de des trafic
de des
narcotrafics allez après pour se faire
peut-être vous me pardonnerez ce
caractère un peu égocentré un peu
plaisir quand même la junalco seul cette
juridiction à elle toute seule en 2022 a
pu procéder à des saisies qui
correspondent à plus de 9 millions
d'euros c'est pas mal pour une
juridiction qui s'achemine mais il faut
faire encore mieux et c'est notamment
dans ce type de sujet que nous sommes je
dirais à la course pour avoir des
méthodologies encore plus efficaces pour
saisir encore davantage alors je dis que
c'est peu mais ça embête toujours parce
que très significativement dès que des
saisis sont opérées je parle sous le
contrôle de Madame la première
vice-présidente il y a des appels
immédiats et ça fait partie quasiment
plus d'appels parce qu'on saisit que
d'appel parce qu'on met en détention ce
qui est assez extraordinaire et ça
prouve que l'on embête tout de même euh
donc un recours pourquoi c'est c'est
cette menace est sans limite vous l'avez
vu un recours à la violence sans limite
aussi une sévère aggravation des guerres
claniques et des règlements de compte on
le constate maintenant sur tout le
territoire deux exemples chez nous à la
junalco aussi je pourrais les multiplier
mais j'ai essayé de de vous faire
percevoir ce qu'on vit au concret un
assassinat en pleine rue à Paris du du
haut figure du banditisme marseillais
autre exemple aussi un dossier qui chez
nous répond à l'acronyme de Trudi c'est
le nom du navire un navire est
intercepté il a un certain nombre de
quantité de cocaïne à bord il est donc
les juges d'instruction sont saisis il
est dans le port du Havre on pense avoir
décharger de ce navire toute la cocaïne
un certain nombre de personnes sont
placées en détention et alors que
l'équipage est resté à bord parce que le
navire doit repartir et bien une un
commando va investir le navire à nouveau
va séquestrer et violenter l'équipage
resté à bord pour récupérer quelque
chose qui leur semblait à juste titre on
le découverr après encore leur
appartenir le navire va continuer et on
va découvrir encore après 500 kg de
cocaïne donc alors qu'il savaiit que la
justiceen était emparée parce que
l'affaire était déjà médiatisée ils
n'ont pas hésité à investir le navire
sur la protection judiciaire une
capacité de corruption
aussi qu'il faut prendre en compte c'est
un danger majeur de la grande
criminalité organisée on le sait on le
voit dans les affaires les dockers les
policiers les agents des douanes les
greffiers les agents pénitentiaires la
lecture pénitence la lecture apporte
très clairement la démonstration de
cette infiltration alors c'est menace et
corruption c'est les deux phases d'une
monnaie de la grande criminalité
organisée mais là aussi un souvenir
christolien quand j'étais procureur
crtaille m'a démontré que même dans les
petites villes ces capacités de
corruption existaient puisque j'ai le
souvenir d'un dossier où c'était un
agent municipal qui avait été corrompu
pour laisser les locaux municipaux à
disposition des trafiquants pour y
entreposer leurs produits pensant que on
nirait jamais chercher là alors pourquoi
d'autres secteurs seraient-il épargné
quand je vous dis ça je pense que la
magistrature nous sommes pas forcément
des incorruptible absolu et pourquoi
échapperions-nous à ces tentatives
d'attaque euh les dirigeants
d'entreprise de transport la situation
économique fragilise les entreprises on
vient au tribunal de commerce on rachète
une entreprise de véhicules de secours
des ambulances par exemple mon audition
est filmée je voudrais pas donner d'idée
au trafiquant mais bon c'est ça peut
être ça peut être une réalité plus les
professions assermenté aussi les
notaires pour qu'il ne fassent pas de
déclaration de soupçon à
traacf je pourrais les banquiers les
avocats pour faire faisant fil leur
secret professionnel qui révèle ce qu'il
y a au
dossier et puis je pourrais multiplier à
l'envie aujourd'hui une des grandes
interrogations qu'on a c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'évasion
judiciaire ça consiste c'est pas une
évasion très spectaculaire c'est pas
force d'hélicoptère ça consiste tout
simplement si on est arrivé à corrompre
un greffier d'une maison d'arrêt à ne
pas envoyer dans les délais la demande
de mise en liberté qui entraîne une
remise en liberté d'office par
difficulté
procédurale alors le défi est immense la
junalcou avance très rapidement je crois
qu'on peut dire qu'elle a su nouer des
liens précieux avec les Gears et qu'elle
joue un rôle de coordinateur de
coordination important parce que même si
je vous ai dit que nous étions sur le
haut spectre de la criminalité organisée
il nous est nécessaire de connaître les
phénomènes locaux pour créer des liens
des rapprochements et lutter sur les
réseaux de très grande criminalité
organisé subséquent
euh je dirais succès de la junalco parce
que maintenant elle bénéficie d'une
reconnaissance internationale
c'est-à-dire que la France s positionnée
à l'international comme un pays qui a
qui se veut dans la lutte sur la très
grande criminalité organisée et on
arrive à avoir des la coopération tout à
fait opérationnelle avec la Colombie les
États-Unis la République tchèque
l'Israël et bien d'autres pays la
coopération judiciaire je vous l'ai dit
elle est
fluide je passe rapidement je répondrai
à vos questions nous répondrons à vos
questions si vous souhaitz mais vous
voyez il y a quelquefois des petits
billets je vous ai dit les difficultés
notamment avec Dubaï un magistrat de
liaison va y être installé ça donne des
perspectives je pense de progrès mais
par exemple en Espagne alors qu'il y a
un magistrat antidrogue lorsqu'on fait
des demandes d'enquête elles sont
déclinées au niveau des parquets locaux
et sont dans la masse et donc on a
quelquefois des délais qui sont
incompatibles avec les
missions aujourd'hui je dirais que les
magistrats de la junalco sont
constamment en lien avec l'international
constamment en lien avec les serv locaux
avec les services d'enquête nous restons
mobilisés nous restons mobilisés en
cybercriminalité parce que il faut
continuer de photographier l'existant
les actions se poursuivent pour pénétrer
les nouveaux réseaux cryptés extraire
les données sans éveiller l'attention
des utilisateurs et c'est par la cyber
qu'on attaquera la
cryptoonnaie qui est une difficulté une
volonté de saisine et de d'appréhension
qui est pour nous essentielle la
criminalité organisé on continue
d'observer les liens évidemment des des
crimes international ils s'adaptent
constamment ils savent qu'on a repéré un
système je dirais que le surlendemain
ils ont trouvé une autre méthodologie
d'introduction des produits il faut
identifier les nouvelles porosités ne
croyez pas que la mafia chinoise ne
coopère pas avec la mafia marocaine
c'est peut-être une image qu'on peut en
avoir elle est fausse si on peut se
servir les uns les autres la porosité
des réseaux criminels existera
la criminalité organisée financière
évidemment il faut continuer à
s'attaquer au carburant de la grande
criminalité organisée c'est-à-dire
l'argent leur argent sale à blanchir et
ça c'est il faut continuer à comprendre
les modalités complexes de dissimulation
des produits autre avancé significatif
pour la junalco vous en aurez parlé sans
doute avant vos travaux je n'ai pas
écouté toutes vos auditions mais au
regard de l'article 76 106-1 du code de
procédure pénale les liens avec le
renseignement judiciaire aujourd'hui de
plus en plus de dossiers de la junalco
sont ouverts grâce à ce type de de
renseignement et avec les services de
renseignement et donc c'est très
précieux parce qu'il faut progresser
dans notre capacité de judiciarisation
il faut aussi progresser dans la
capacité des services de renseignement
et on sait à quel point ils ont d'autres
thématiques de de de s'investir dans la
lutte contre la criminalité organisée
hein c'est pas par hasard si le code de
sécurité intérieure dit que dans la
défense des intérêts de la fondamentaux
de la nation il y a la prévention de la
criminalité organisée et de la
délinquence organisée donc voilà à peu
près ce sur quoi nous avons progressé
beaucoup reste à faire encore
l'espérance d'évolution législative
au-delà de l'espérance de moyens je l'ai
dit je vais le dire je vais le répéter
vous l'aurez compris ça fait partie de
la charge qu'un tout chef de juridiction
de d'attirer votre attention sur ce
point mais les évolutions législatives
qui mérite d'être exploré à notre sens
une évolution du de de la notion de
repenti il faut qu'on essaie d'évoluer à
l'image de de la loi antimafia italienne
je pense il faut aussi étendre notre
possibilité de confiscation du
patrimoine des des criminels et cette
exigence de
proportionnalité qui qui nous conduit à
quelquefois ne pas pouvoir saisir tout
voilà il faudrait peut-être me permettre
d'évoluer de façon légistique sur ce
point je pense qu'il faut que votre
commission d'enquête réfléchisse à une
cour d'ASS spécialement composé alors
elle existe déjà en matière de
stupéfiant c'està-dire ce sont que des
magistrats professionnels mais elle
n'existe pas en matière de réglement de
compte et dans les phénomènes de
règlement de compte si on si on y
assortit pas un titre connexe une
infraction qui permettrait d'une cours
d'assis spécialement composée vous allez
avoir des jurés qui vont juger des
règlements de compte à haut niveau et je
là pour le coup je n'invente pas un
exemple tout à fait récent à bobini
démontre que tes jurés ont été approchés
pour pour être menacé très clairement
pour avoir une influence dans les dans
le délibéré il faut prévoir un droit
d'application des peine spéciale il faut
un juge d'application des peines
spécialisé gérer une personnalité de
grande criminalité organisée c'est
différent que git un délinquant de droit
commun me
semble-t-il il faut aussi rendre plus
sévères les conditions de
détention parce qu'il ne faut trouver
des moyens pour interdire que les
délinquants continuent à gérer leur
trafic direction du groupe criminel et
enfin il faut encadrer par un formalisme
augmenté les appels des décision
relative à des des détentions
provisoires ça évitera les évasions
judiciaires que j'évoqué au début de mon
propos je vous ai donné une certaine
feuille de route mais croyez bien que la
mienne est importante aussi merci de
votre
attention merci c'était très clair sur
les attendus le constat et sur les
besoins merci
notre rapporteur très bien merci de cet
exposé
liminire après 5 années
d'exerciceactivité de la junalco et
quelles sont les évolutions essentielles
que vous pourriez nous donner sur le
trafic de stupéfiants sur le blanchiment
et sur l'ensemble de ces réseaux
qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus marqué
pendant ces 5
années à la
foruction
peut-être avant de répondre à votre
question pardon merci avant de répondre
à vos à votre question je va peut-être
en fait présenter un petit peu euh le
Paul girgunalco à l'instruction pour la
criminalité organisée et aussi essayer à
mon niveau enfin au niveau de
l'instruction d'apporter un certain
nombre de réponses au questionnaires que
vous nous aviez adressé
euh une petite précision pour commencer
donc à Paris ce sont les mêmes juges qui
œuvrent pour les dossiers JIRS et les
dossiers junalco le contentionon est le
même en fait c'est le degré en fait de
grande complexité qui varie euh ça vous
a été indiqué par Monsieur le Président
la girgeunalco en matière de criminalité
organisée à Paris c'est actuellement
neuf cabinets
d'instruction euh très rapidement la
mesure a été prise en fait de ce
qu'était cette juridiction et plusieurs
cabinets d'instruction ont été créés en
fait pour donner à cette
junalco les moyens pour instruire les
dossiers chaque cabinet est composé d'un
juge d'un greffier les collègues ça vous
a été rappelé par Monsieur le Président
sont criblés en fait pour arriver dans
le service ce sont des collègues
volontaires et des collègues qui sont
dotés d'une grande expérience à la fois
à l'instruction et à la fois sur les
sujets de criminalité organisé notre
service dispose d'une directrice de
Greff de deux adjoints administratif qui
s'occupe du secrétariat et la
numérisation de nos dossiers nous
disposons par ailleurs s'agissant de
l'équipe autour du juge d'un assistant
spécialisé en matière de téléphonie que
nous sommes C censés partager avec les
collègues d'un autre pôle mais dans
l'ffet il ne travaille que pour nous la
situation est en cours d'évolution
puisque nous allons avoir un autre
assistant spécialisé qui va s'occuper de
la saisie des avoirs et de l'entraide
pénale internationale et également un
juriste assistant qui va nous aider dans
la rédaction de nos actes les les
dossiers que nous traitons à la geirs
junalco ont des caractéristiques
différent en fait des dossiers qu'on va
retrouver dans les cabinets de droits
commun ce sont des dossiers en fait dont
la volum la dont la volumétrie pardon
est importante pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée chaque cabinet instruit entre 25
et 35 dossiers et gère à peu près entre
40 et 90 détenus alors le nombre de
dossierers peut ne pas apparaître
important mais en
réalité ce nombre est suffisamment
important pour qu'on puisse continuer à
mener je dirais une action efficace ces
dossiers ont la particularité d'être
extrêmement volumineux euh 20 t 30 40
50ô 100ô de fond ce sont des dossiers
complexes nous pouvons être amenés à
rédiger en fait des centaines de
décisions liées à des techniques
spéciales d'enquête hein des écoutes
téléphoniques des géolocalisations et
cetera il faut savoir que dans ces
dossiers ça a été rappelé par Madame la
procureur de la République
systématiquement nous avons du
contentieux sur les nulités des requêes
en nulité sont faites dans quasiment
enfin pas dans quasiment dans tous les
dossiers et ces personnes sont défendues
par des avocats qui sont très
spécialisés dans le domaine et qui sont
très offensifs ces dossiers volumineux
nécessitent de la part des juges
d'instruction une direction d'enquête
importante et une coordination aussi des
services enquêteurs ça vous AZ été
rappelé par Madame la procureure à
l'international ce sont des dossiers
aussi qui nécessitent euh un travail
très important les phases de coopération
dans ce dossier sont très importantes ce
sont des dossiers qui sont très
chronophages en temps de réunion et en
temps de déplacement de juges à
l'international les pour les dossiers
nous sommes aussi de plus en plus
fréquemment associé à des collègues en
fait de nos autres pôles du pôle
financier et du pôle cyber criminalité
notamment sur les dossiers qui portent
en fait sur les solutions de téléphonie
cryptée sur les dossiers junalco nous
sommes aussi systématiquement en caisine
à deux ou trois juges d'instruction
compte tenu en fait de l'importance de
ces dossiers ce qui a aussi l'intérêt et
le mérite que si un des collègues en
fait s'en va vous avez toujours un
collègue qui a cette connaissance des
dossiers plus de la moitié de notre
portefeuille est constitué de dossiers
liés au trafic de stupéfiants et nous
avons aussi les dossiers qui en sont le
corollaire à savoir les dossiers de
blanchiment mais aussi les dossiers de
violence criminelle ça vient de vous
être rappelé qui englobent les homicides
et les tentatives d'homicide en bande
organisé les enlèvements séquestration
sur fond de trafic de stupéfiants tout
ce qu'on qui rentrerait sous le vocable
aussi de règlement de compte le reste de
nos dossiers est constitué des dossiers
de trafic de migrants de des gros
dossiers de braquage de proxénétisme de
traite des êtres humains de blanchiment
de trafic d'armes d'association de
malfaiteurs d'évasion de haut niveau de
vol en band organisé les dossiers de
trafic de stupéfiant que nous
instruisons porte principalement sur les
trafics de cocaïne et de cannabis le
trafic de cocaïne a véritablement
explosé je pense qu'on peut employer
cette expression ces dernières années
avec une montée en puissance
véritablement très importante nous avons
en fait plusieurs typologies de dossiers
liés au trafic de stupéfiants des
dossiers portuaires ou aéroportuaires à
savoir des importations directement
depuis l'Amérique du Sud avec des
arrivées dans des ports français comme
Le Havre d'unquer
fausse avec la complicité de docker ou
de personnel de société de logistique
nous avons aussi des dossierers de
narcotrafic de cité le plus souvent avec
des importations de cannabis du Maroc
via l'Espagne et des remontées en convoi
par des poids lourds des véhicules
légers et des saisies pouvant atteindre
des centaines de kilos voire des tonnes
nos dossiers portent principalement je
l'ai indiqué sur de la cocaïne et du
cannabis nous n'avons pas de dossier en
matière d'héroïne et aucun dossier au
sein nous avons pardon un seul dossier
pardon en matière d'héroïne et aucun
dossier au sein du pôle sur les drogues
de synthèse qui doivent être aussi un
sujet de
préoccupation la plupart des dossiers
junalco qui ont été ouverts sont des
dossiers qui ont prospéré et le premier
dossier junalco a été jugé récemment
mais c'est un dossier qui ne portait pas
sur du trafic de stupéfiant mais sur du
trafic de migrants actuellement au sein
du pôle nous avons 43 dossiers junalco
et se dossiers Jun avec avec les
stampill junalco ont été ouverts depuis
le début de
l'année cela vous a été indiqué la j
junalco travaille sur le haut du spectre
des organisations criminelles les
évolutions que l'on peut constater en
fait dans le cadre du narcotrafic depuis
la création de la junalco s'inscrivent
dans une évolution à mon sens déjà
amorcée en réalité depuis plusieurs
années avec une montée en puissance des
trafique de stupéfiants les
organisations criminelles les réseaux se
sont se sont professionnalisé au fur et
à mesure des années elles utilisent une
main d'œuvre qu'ell recrut comme le
ferait en fait n'importe quel chef
d'entreprise sur certains réseaux
sociaux vous allez trouver des
organisations qui proposent des offres
d'emploi avec des prix pour recruter un
charbonneur un
guetteteur pour le règlement de compte
le même phénomène est constaté à savoir
que les organisations vont faire appel à
des équipes spécifiques pour aller tuer
telle ou telle personne séquestrer ou
enlever telle ou telle personne le
trafic de stupéfiant c'est complexifié
et mondialisé à l'image de ce qui se
passe en fait dans notre société ces
structures sont très organisées elles
apprennent elles savent s'adapter pour
déjouer les méthodes d'enquête classique
elles ont appris de nos méthodes de
fonctionnement au niveau police et
justice et elles savent s'adapter en
fait pour échapper aux forces de l'ordre
ce qui rend bien évidemment beaucoup
plus complexes les dossiers traité nos
dossiers judiciaires sont régis par le
principe du contradictoire et on expose
ce tout ce qu'on fait en fait et comment
on le fait dans nos dossiers ce qui
permet aux trafiquants de comprendre en
fait leur point de fragilité de savoir
en fait comment ils ont été interpellés
et de pouvoir
s'adapter pour ce qui est des techniques
spéciales
d'enquête un certain nombre de
dispositifs sont encore utilisés mais
parfois à des fins un peu secondaires il
est très rare aujourd'hui d'avoir des
trafiquants de stupéfiants qui vont
parler en clair sur des écoutes
téléphoniques ils vont utiliser des
applications de messagerie crypté dont
ils savent qu'on ne peut pas les
intercepter et nous sommes constamment
obligés de nous adapter je dois préciser
aussi que dans les dossiers de trafic de
stupéfiants le travail de téléphonie est
un travail devenu très important la
junalco a pu prendre en charge de très
gros dossiers qui impliqueent plusieurs
geirs ou aussi des dossiers où tout est
déterritorialisé cela vous a été indiqué
par Madame la procureure mais euh le il
faut sou souligner que le le décryptage
des solutions de téléphonie cryptée en
crotchat et skycc a été concomitant avec
la mise en place en fait de la junalco
et a contribué à alimenter plusieurs
dossiers importants ces éléments ont
permis en fait de découvrir des
trafiquants qui étaient passés
complètement en fait sous les radars euh
des services et et on a pu aussi avoir
accès en clair à des communications très
éclairantes et aussi surtout très
incriminantes pour ces trafic et
organisation en terme d'éléments de
preuve le constat qu'on peut faire c'est
que nous sommes très souvent désormais
en présence aussi de trafiquants
français qui continuent de trafiquer
mais qui se trouvent établis à
l'étranger qui sont établis
temporairement ou durablement dans
d'autres pays comme aux Émirats dans des
pays du Maghreb en Espagne en dans
certains pays d'Amérique du
et que ces individus c'est un constat
que l'on fait dans nos dossiers
continuent de se déplacer en dépit de
mandat d'arrêt internationaux ou de
mandat d'arrêt européen comment est-il
possible que des individus ciblés par
des mandats comme internationaux ou des
mandats d'arrêt européens puissent
continuer à se déplacer de la sorte deux
réponses ils utilisent parfois de
fausses identités il y a tout un un
trafic de faux papiers qui est lié en
fait à au trafic de stupéfiant et
parfois aussi ils utilisent leur vraie
identité et là se pose la question en
fait du système de coopération dont on
peut dont on peut dire dans certains cas
qu'il peut-être
perfectible nous sommes aussi en
présence de trafiquants qui continuent
parfois de trafiquer depuis leur lieux
de détention et de trafiquer à haut
niveau ils le font parce qu'ils arrivent
à se procurer en fait des téléphones
pour pour pouvoir communiquer avec
l'extérieur et ça aussi c'est un réel
élément de complexité le travail sur ces
organisation en fait nécessite de
repenser en fait complètement nos
schémas d'enquête classique ça vous a
été indiqué par Madame la procureure la
junealco c'est encore une juridiction
jeune mais elle a elle doit avoir cette
vision globale au niveau du réseau des
girirs et cette fonction surtout de
coordination et cela suppose que tous
les acteurs à chaque niveau en fait
jouent le jeu de la remontée
d'information et de la
coordination cela suppose aussi que
cette remontée d'information nous
puissions la traiter et être à la
hauteur des enjeux et aussi au niveau de
ce qu'on est en droit d'attendre en fait
d'une juridiction
nationale s'agissant du renseignement
criminel madame la procureure vous l'a
indiqué mais celui-ci prend
effectivement une part de plus en plus
importante les choses ont évolué parce
que à l'origine ce n'était pas du tout
dans notre culture de de magistrat mais
c'est désormais quelque chose que nous
intégrons sur la grande criminalité
organisée pour ce qui est de
l'instruction cela passe souvent en fait
par l'intermédiation du parquet mais
surtout des services enquêteurs et le
renseignement en matière criminelle va
être le plus souvent un point de départ
pour une enquête
judiciaire s'agissant du bilan des JIRS
je dirais à mon niveau que ce bilan je
le trouve plutôt positif positif pardon
la spécialisation des acteurs de la
chaîne pénale et le fonctionnement en
réseau en fait le fait que les collègues
se connaissent davantage et soit
identifié comme tel à mon sens a permis
de renforcer l'efficacité sur la lutte
contre les trafic c'était indispensable
au regard en fait de la
professionnalisation de ces
organisations cela a permis aussi de
développer davantage la coopération
internationale bien plus qu'un juge
d'instruction de droit commun en fait ne
pourrait le faire et d'être aussi
identifié par nos partenaires étrangers
sur le réseau geirs et le réseau
junalco s'agissant du logiciel Siroco
qui est un logiciel de recoupement et
d'orientation euh on est au balbuement
en fait et à la mise en place en fait de
ce logiciel dont nous n'avons pas encore
la pleine maîtrise mais sa création est
née en fait d'un besoin qui avait été
identifié ce logiciel est une bonne
chose mais comme tout nouvel outil il
demande en fait des ajustements et un
temps d'appropriation des amendements
sur certains aspects qu'on ne peut
constater en fait que lorsqu'on le met
en œuvre pratiquement sur la question de
savoir si nous avons besoin de
traitement de données et si nous avons
recours à d'autres technologies il faut
préciser que tout juge GIR ce que nous
sommes nous sommes considérés comme des
juges d'instruction en fait comme les
autres et avant de parler du recours à
des nouvelles technologies il faut
savoir que nos applicatifs métiers et
notre environnement informatique sont
totalement inadaptés à nos besoins et à
la volumétrie en fait de nos dossiers
pour comprendre nos dossiers sont
volumineux 20 30 50 côes parfois avec
beaucoup de parties beaucoup de mis en
examen beaucoup de parties civiles
beaucoup de données aussi
intrinsèquement à traiter en fait dans
les dossiers notre logiciel métier
Cassiopé est un logiciel lent qui manque
de fluidité par rapport au logiciel que
nous avons pu connaître auparavant mais
qui était dépassé car trop ancien ce
logiciel ne nous permet pas en outre de
sortir de statistiqu exactes ce qui
impose par parfois des comptages manuels
assez arid notre logiciel de
numérisation NPP connaît constamment des
difficultés nous n'avons pas assez de
capacité de stockage le réseau est
souvent lent ce qui induit beaucoup de
ralentissement et de lenteur nos
dossiers sont très volumineux et notre
serveur pour vous dire à Paris
actuellement est rempli à 99 %. nos
ordinateurs sont ce qu'on peut
entendre parfaitement pour des raisons
de sécurité mais nous sommes en
difficulté pour exploiter parfois
certains résultats d'experti
pour donner par exemple un exemple
certains fichiers ne vont pas s'ouvrir
parce qu'ils sont trop volumineux par
rapport à la capacité de notre
ordinateur ou alors vont mettre de jours
à s'ouvrir c'est une difficulté que nous
rencontrons en fait dans tous les dans
tous les pôles spécialisés hein nos
collègues du financier ou de la cyber
connaissent les mêmes difficultés et qui
touchent aussi nos collègues du service
général c'est une complication aussi
pour nos greffes dans le traitement en
fait des dossiers et cela complique cela
complique de façon général en fait le
traitement de nos dossiers qui est déjà
un traitement
complexe les Girs la junalco ont fait
apparaître le besoin croissant d'analyse
criminelle nous avons actuellement un
assistant spécialisé pour neuf cabinets
rien que pour l'analyse criminelle
c'est-à-dire analyser en fait les
données faire des liens nous aurions
besoin au moins de deux assistants
supplémentaires pour traiter tout ce que
nous avons à traiter les services
d'enquête à cet égard sont également
démunis on passe parfois par des experts
mais les expertises ont un coût le
nombre d'experts qui maîtrisent ce
savoir-faire est assez limité et par
ailleurs certains experts ne veulent
plus travailler avec nous parce qu'ils
sont payés avec beaucoup de retard au
titre des frais de justice et je pense
que là aussi nous avons des marches de
progression en la
matière s'agissant des aspects de
coopération internationale je dirais
qu'il y a eu des avancées majeures quand
même en 20 ans l'évolution a été très
importante la décision d'enquête
européenne le mandat d'arrêt européen le
certificat de gel ont été des avancées
majeures pour nos dossiers au sein de
l'espace Schengen globalement nous
pouvons indiquer que le constat est
plutôt très satisfaisant et plutôt
positif la difficulté vient une fois
qu'on sort de l'Europe puisque là cela
dépend vraiment des pays et il est assez
difficile en fait de faire des
généralités avec certains pays la
coopération sur certains dossiers va
très bien fonctionner et avec le même
pays sur un autre dossier la coopération
ne va pas du tout fonctionner sans que
de l'extérieur nous puissions l'analyser
en fait de façon rationnelle nos plus
gros trafiquants se sont se sont
installés dans des pays dont ils savent
que leur extradition ne sera pas
possible ou qu'elle sera à tout le moins
extrêmement compliquée de même ils ont
aussi parfaitement compris que la saisie
de leurs avoirs criminels serait
beaucoup plus compliqué si elle était à
l'étranger et non pas en France les
contacts directs entre magistrats
français et étrangers le fait de se
déplacer est un vrai facilitateur et je
dois aussi souligner euh l'important
soutien euh d'Eurojust qui apporte une
contribution très importante sur
l'aspect de coopération euh dans nos
dossiers en dehors de l'État en dehors
de de l'Europe pardon il y a des états
avec lesquels nous n'avons pas de
conventions bilatérales ou multilatéral
ce qui rend en fait la coopération très
compliquée et enfin les aléases je
dirais de la géopolitique mondiale ont
une incidence direct sur le traitement
de nos dossiers s'agissant des liens
entre le trafic de stupéfiants et les
autres types de réseaux criminels ces
organisation euh s'associent entre elles
ou font appel euh les unes aux autres
pour blanchir des fonds elles vont faire
appel à des réseaux de collecteur pour
communiquer elles vont faire appel à des
organisations qui vendent des systèmes
de téléphonie réputés inviolable ces
organisations savent s'associer et
savent se partager certains territoires
s'agissant de la direction des enquêtes
complexes et l'inquiétude qui avait été
mentionnée dans votre questionnaire
l'inquiétude des parquets cette
inquiétude elle est partagée également
du côté de l'instruction compte tenu de
de l'état de l'investigation en général
particulièrement en sécurité publique la
réforme de la police judiciaire qui va
entrer en qui est en train d'entrer en
vigueur nous fait craindre que les
effectifs de police judiciaire ne soient
absorber pour éponger ces procédures en
retard nous avons la crainte à
l'instruction d'une diluion d'un
savoir-faire et d'une perte de qualité
les directives seront fixées par le
préfet et le directeur territorial de la
police quelle sera la place laissée au
procureur et au juges d'instruction en
terme de direction d'enquête si les
objectifs poursuivis ne sont pas les
mêmes par ailleurs alors même que nous
avons des organisation qui uvre à
l'international et à tout le moins à
l'échelle du territoire national le
choix du département ne manque pas de
nous interroger alors même que quelques
années auparavant ont été é créé en fait
des directions zonales laissera-t-on
encore nos enquêteurs travailler sur le
haut du spectre de la criminalité quand
la priorité médiatique sera donnée à tel
sera donné à tel ou tel objectif il est
clair que les offices centraux ne
pourront pas tout absorber et qu'ils
travaillent déjà relativement souvent en
cisine avec des services de police
judiciire territoriaux et enfin pour des
équipes itinérantes quand plusieurs sont
impactés il n'est pas aisé de découvrir
en l'état actuel que des faits commis en
plusieurs endroits du territoire sont en
réalité le fait d'une seule et même
équipe ce découpage nous interroge en
fait pour la criminalité que nous
traitons s'agissant des évolutions
législatives Madame le Procureur vous en
a parlé sur la saisie des avoirs
criminels ce qui nous manque je dirais
le plus fréquemment en terme de saisie
des avoirs criminels c'est le travail
d'identification dans nos dossiers de
trafic de stupéfiants nous ne pouvons
pas demander à nos services d'enquête
qui se consacr déjà à des enquêtes très
complexes sur les stupéfiants de faire
ce travail qui relève davantage de
services à caractère financier or les
effectifs de ces services sont
sousdimensionné déjà pour travailler sur
leur matière c'est une difficulté
importante d'autant plus quand les
avoirs sont situés à l'étranger une
autre difficulté aussi réside parfois
pour nous dans le temps pour rédiger ces
ordonnances et c'est là que l'équipe du
juge prend tout son sens s'agissant de
l'exploitation des données nous avons
aussi une source d'inquiétude qui vient
d'une récente jurisprudence de la
chambre criminale de la Cour de
cassation qui a conduit en fait à
modifier profondément les pratiques et
qui vise à exiger une motivation en fait
pour chaque facturation détaillée de
numéros demandé la criminalité organisée
et l'antiterrorisme ont paru un temps
relativement préservé nos dossiers
reposent sur un travail de téléphonie
qui est extrêmement important si nous
devons vons motiver chaque demande pour
un numéro par les enquêteurs nous allons
perdre un temps précieux perdre en
efficacité alors que nos enquêteurs
travaillent sur des centaines voir sur
des milliers de numéros les moyens pour
travailler sur ces réseaux ne sont pas
infinis on ajoute et on complexifie de
plus en plus les enquêtes et cela
profite en réalité à des criminels du
haut du spectre et la désertification
quand même d'un certain nombre
d'enquêteurs de l'investigation peut
peut-être se comprendre euh à l'Ô de ce
que je viens
d'indiquer euh s'agissant de la
procédure coffre qui a été évoqué nous
n'avons pas dans notre arsenal
législatif actuel euh cette procédure
euh d coffre euh mais cela moi m'évoque
euh l'exemple belge les Belges ont ce
qu'ils appellent le dossier dit
confidentiel euh pour être en contact
avec des collègues belges voilà ce
qu'ils m'ont indiqué dans le dispositif
juridique belge ce dossier dit
confidentiel n'est accessible qu'au
procureur qui a ce qu'il appelle les
méthodes particulières dans ses
attributions et trois conseiller de la
cour d'appel sont chargés du contrôle de
la légalité des méthodes trois méthodes
peuvent faire l'objet d'un dossier
confidentiel en résumé la première est
le recours aux indicateurs cette méthode
ne fait l'objet d'aucun contrôle par la
cour d'appel et est gérée par le
procureur exclusivement la second est
l'infiltration soit par policier sous
couverture euh soit par un civil étant
précisé qu'en France nous ne connaissons
pas d'infiltration euh par des civils et
ne sont mis en procédure dans le dossier
belge que les élément d'exécution mais
tout le reste se trouve dans le dossier
confidentiel le troisème est
l'observation avec moyen techniques les
techniques sont protégés comme ça les
suspects ne savent jamais ce qu'on a
utilisé pour les observer tout cela fait
l'objet du dossier confidentiel les
collègues belges estime que le dossier
confidentiel est utile car cela leur
permet de mettre des choses en
procédures secrète que seul la cour d'pp
app pour à lire la défense n'a aucun
droit d'accès le secret est validé et
mes collègues m'ont indiqué que cela
avait été validé par la CEDH la pratique
veut aussi que si le juge d'instruction
le souhaite le parquet lui communique le
dossier
confidentiel
doit-on adopter un tel dispositif un tel
dispositif en France le fait est que
nous devons travailler en France sur
plusieurs aspects cela vous a été
indiqué par Madame la procureure
les infiltrations nous ne pratiquons pas
suffisamment les infiltrations dans nos
dossiers la question des informateurs
aussi et de leur statut qui est aussi
lié à la question de la sécurité
juridique pour les enquêteurs ayant
recours aux informateurs et à mon sens
la question des infiltrations et des
informateurs en fait doit être traitée
de concerts voilà dernier point que je
souhaiterais souligner c'est celui cela
vous vous a été indiqué aussi par Madame
le Procureur relatif à la corruption et
à la compromission la question de la
corruption elle est de plus en plus
présente dans nos dossiers nous devons
l'intégrer davantage ces organisations
ont une surface financière qu'on
n'imagine pas en réalité tellement elle
est importante le pouvoir corrupteur de
ces organisations est un phénomène en
expansion ces mêmes organisations
disposent d'armement important également
les saisis de stupéfiants s'accompagnent
presque systématiquement de saisis
d'armes d'armes de guerre ces
organisations entendent aussi contrôler
parfois certains points du territoire de
la République ces éléments doivent à mon
sens être pris en compte très
sérieusement au vu de ce que nos voisins
belges et néerlandais connaissent déjà
nous ne sommes pas différent et cela
pointe déjà dans nos
dossiers merci beaucoup on passe une
matinée extrêmement enrichissante là je
crois qu'on a beaucoup de matériaux et
je vais donner la parole à nos collègues
par le rapporteur il a trouvé son compte
je crois dans vos propos j'ai Didier
rambau Roger carucci merci merci Laur
burgois on prend les les interventions
merci président alors effectivement une
question sur vos moyens d'investigation
et et plus particulièrement s la sous
cette fonction de d'indicateur ou de
comment vous a dit d'informateur vous
l'avez venez d'un peu de de de d'en
parler c'est vrai qu' il y a beaucoup de
de mystères ou de de fantasmes un petit
peu autour de cette fonction hein on
voit un peu dans les film et cetera que
c'est un personnage qui est un peu clé
euh mais voilà j'avoue je suis très naïf
c'est quelque chose d'officiel c'est une
c'est un c'est une fonction c'est c'est
secret c'est voilà merci de d'apporter
de un éclairage à ce sujet
oui il s'agit att peut-être qu'on va
prendre excusez-moi prendre les trois
questions comme ça on gagnera du temps
Roger caroucier Laurant burgois
oui moi au fur à mesure des des
auditions je finis par me dire que je
n'ai pas de question spécifique mais une
question globale plutôt
euh les les services nous ont dit en
gros difficile à jauger mais le trafic
de drogue représente à peu près 250
milliards d'euros dans le monde et
probablement entre 5 et 6 milliards en
France vous nous dites un certain nombre
de choses sur les évolutions depuis 2019
sur euh l'augmentation des moyens mais
on sent bien chaque fois euh les
limites limite en moyens matériel limite
en moyens humains limite
euh dans le domaine du droit sur par
exemple on vient de l'entendre les
conditions de
détention des principaux criminels qui
pourraient continuer ou qui peuvent
continuer à trafiquer depuis leur lieux
de
détention limite sur la coopération
internationale on se dit finalement
est-ce que nous ne sommes pas encore et
là-dessus sur un un jeu à somme nul mais
nul pour nous c'est-à-dire quand nous
nous obtenons 10 les trafiquants eux
sont à 100 ils ont visiblement des
moyens matériels bien supérieurs au
nôtres des moyens informatiques bien
supérieurs des réseaux cryptés bien
supérieurs on a un peu l'impression
qu'on court en permanence derrière alors
est-ce que
finalement faudrait pas que les pouvoirs
publics quand je dis pouvoirs public
c'est le gouvernement et le Parlement ne
se saisissent pas de cette affaire en
disant mais tant qu'il y a pas un plan
d'urgence massif qui serait à la fois un
plan d'urgence sur les conditions
humaines et matérielles renforcé mais
aussi un plan d'urgence sur l'adaptation
de la législation pour mieux lutter
contre ça et en même temps probablement
mais ça c'est plus compliqué c'est pas
nous seul un plan de meilleure
coopération internationale on a un peu
l'impression que la guerre à la drogue
elle se fait avec des guerriers
valeureux mais pas forcément équipé
comme il devrait l'être pour pour la
gagner quoi donc est-ce que un plan
global d'urgence n'est pas nécessaire en
France pour modifier la donne et changer
les équilibres
quoi Laurent burgois oui merci monsieur
le Président tout d'abord mesdames
messieurs vous remerciez les uns et les
autres pour la qualité des informations
et votre franchise euh je trouve que ça
a été remarquable et on passé une une
matinée où j'ai beaucoup appris et vous
dire que peut-être en sortant j'ai un
peu froid au dos euh par rapport à
quelques informations que vous nous avez
donné alors j'auris j'aurais deux
questions une plutôt pourame Aleski
parce que vous avez parlé de l'oration
de votre juridiction qui est une
compéten nationale internationale et le
et les terrains c'està-dire les Gires et
vous avez parlé de d'un lien des liens
et à un moment j'ai senti dans vos
propos mais peut-être je me suis trompé
que des fois l'information ne vous
remonteit pas systématiquement est-ce
que c'est vrai ou est-ce que c'est moi
qui mal compris ou est-ce qu'il faudrait
qu'il améliorer encore ce lien entre les
territoires et et votre compétenence
nationale et international et puis à
vous quatre après vos propos est-ce que
vous avez espoir ou peut-être à Madame
le Procureur que je connais bien puis
puisqu'elle a exercé dans dans un
département qui m'est cher et je connais
je dire sa persévérance est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner une lueur d'espoir
qu'un jour ou l'autre on pourra vaincre
Cees narcotrafiquant je sais pas si
c'est dans la mission de la procureur
mais Olivier
cadiic enc il y en a encore une suis
désolé iv inscrit et je vous propose
qu'on termine à 45 si ça vous va
oui moi en tant que sénateur des
Français établis hors de France ça fait
à peu près 10 ans que j'observe ce qui
se passe en Amérique latine et je crois
qu'on en est encore loin donc on a on
est loin de ce que l'on observe en
Amérique latine puisque on voit un
candidat à la présidence de la
République qui peut être assassiné je ne
parle pas des journalistes qui sont
assassinés mais que que dire des
policiers de leur famille dès lors que
un policier est efficace c'est non
seulement lui mais c'est toute sa
famille qui peut disparaître on voit le
niveau de violence auquel on peut
arriver et je crois que notre rôle ici
c'est d'éviter que sur notre territoire
il arrive la même chose
or il me semble qu'il est difficile pour
nous de
réussir de ce côté-là de l'Atlantique si
on les fait pas réussir aussi de l'autre
côté et c'est un peu le sentiment et
c'est ce que m'ont dit d'ailleurs des
députés brésiliens lien euh il y a 2
semaines quand j'y étais c'est que il y
a besoin qu'on travaille aussi ensemble
au niveau parlementaire pour aligner les
législations parceque vous avez avec
justesse parlé de ce qui se passe en
Belgique et au Pays-Bas où ils sont un
peu plus avancés que nous pour l'instant
dans les effets négatifs que l'on
observe mais vous avez complètement
raison je vous remercie vraiment pour la
façon dont vous appréhendez les choses
et surtout dans avec laquelle vous les
partager en nous demandant aussi de
faire évoluer notre législation c'est
moi ce que j'attends de la commission
d'enquête qu'on travaille tous ensemble
et on sait que pour répondre à notre
collègue que ça va pas on va pas le
faire disparaître puisque leurs moyens
sont tellement élevés que c'est un c'est
vraiment un travail au long cours il y a
un sujet qui apparaît vous avez commencé
à l'esquisser puisque c'est la question
des faux papiers puisque en fait ils se
fondent ils sont on a parlé de moyens
donc pour eux des faux papier des
fausses identités donc se pose la
question effectivement de l'identité
numérique à quel moment on va pouvoir
effectivement nous-mêm reconnaître un
individu non pas pour les papiers qu'
nous présente mais pour la réalité ce
que j'ai dit dans une audition
précédente lorsque nous sommes face à
une personne décédée la seule façon de
nous assurer que cette personne est bien
la personne qu'elle doit être et bien on
l'identifie on a des des moyens est-ce
que il va pas falloir aujourd'hui faire
évoluer notre processus justement pour
repérer les individus euh il y a aussi
je l'ai observé par exemple au Brésil
pour lutter contre les trafics
l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle avec la reconnaissance des
plaques
d'imatriirculation automobile qui permet
justement d'identifier les parcours je
dirais qui ne sont pas réguliers et
automatiquement qui qui permet de de
cibler plus facilement les les gens
est-ce que vous pensez que dans ce
domaine il faut pas aussi faire évoluer
évoluer la loi en terme de observation
de différence de législation si je
regarde d'un côté ou de l'autre de de
l'Atlantique on va parler de la question
des mules qui euh font venir quand même
euh certaine quantité d'héroïes on a pu
déjà en parler dans une audition
précédente j'observe que par exemple au
Pays-Bas jusqu'à 4 kg donc de cocaïne
ils vont détruire la cocaïne et renvoyer
la mule directement j'observe qu'au
Brésil la peine est assez lourde c'est
tout de suite 50 de prisons et ils ne
peuvent pas en FA faire moins alors chez
nous dans une audition il a été dit
plutôt 1 kg 2 kg enfin ça fait 1 an 2
ans un an par kilo mais la grande
question qui se pose et je vous le dis
par rapport aussi au aux personnes qui
qui travaillent c'est une une question
qui m'est remonté de de personnes de nos
services quelle est l'effectivité des
peines réalisées ça c'est une grande
question que l'on se pose parce que on
dit qu'effectivement ils sont qu' ané à
1 an 2 ans de prison quelle est la
réalité l'effectivité des peines sur ce
sujet c'est aussi une question qui qui
se pose à nous pour pour dire c'est si
on fait des textes et que de toute façon
derrière l'application ne se fait pas on
peut se poser la question de où est-ce
qu'on met la jauge entre le Brésil et
puis les Pays-Bas
merci première partie de donc première
question concernant les sources oui
c'est tout à fait officiel ce sont des
sources en réalité la majorité des
affaires dont ce saisit la junalco euh
ont lieu à partir d'un renseignement
c'est-à-dire ce n'est pas du flagrant
délit avec une découverte en flagrance
c'est à partir d'un renseignement et
souvent le renseignement repose sur des
sources les sources sont des personnes
qui sont en lien avec les services
enquêteurs et les services de
renseignement qui sont inscrits qui sont
repérés qui sont officiels et que nous
autorités judiciairees nous ne
connaissons pas nominativement par
contre il y a transparence entre le
services enquêteur et de renseignement
et le parquet puisque toutes ces de la
junalco commence par un rendez-vous
physique au tribunal au parquet avec le
service enquêteur qui vient exposer son
affaire pour envisager la cine de la
junalco et donc la la source est quelque
chose d'officiel et qui est inscrite
donc c'est pas quelque chose qui est
clandestin c'est quelque chose qui est
répertorié contrôlé le cas échéant
rémunéré avec de l'argent public et et
et est tracé voilà par les services donc
c'est quelque chose qui est
officiel monsieur le sénateur kouci a
posé une question tout à fait je dirais
pertinente
sur les priorités peut-être et c'est
vrai que c'est une question que nous
nous posons souvent dans les
juridictions la juridiction parisiennees
aussi de se dire où est-ce que l'on met
la priorité lorsque tout est prioritaire
où est-ce que nous mettons la ressource
lorsque tout est
prioritaire je crois que
on peut rester un petit peu optimiste
quand même par rapport à
cela la détermination de politique
judiciaire prioritaire n'est toujours
d'actualité je crois que là nous n'avons
n n'avançons pas sur ce
sujet le Parlement a récemment voté une
augmentation considérable des moyens de
de la justice c'est une réalité la
création de postes de magistrat de
greffi d'équipe autour du juge sont ét
attendu depuis des années et des années
donc là nous allons dans le bon sens
j'ajoute que dans le déploiement à venir
des effectifs qui vont rejoindre les
juridictions le ministère a bien
conscience qu'il faut réserver une
partie de ces effectifs aux principales
juridictions qui sont concerné par les
luttes contre les affaires les plus
compliquées et Paris bien évidemment
doit bénéficier d'une ressource adaptée
notamment au besoins de la criunalité
organisée je crois que ça nous serons au
rendez-vous là où nous devons être très
vigilants en terme d'amélioration de la
réponse judiciaire de la réponse de
l'État et ça rejoint la modernisation de
l'État c'est l'informatique le numérique
demain l'intelligence artificielle pour
exploiter au mieux ces dossiers là nous
accumulons depuis des années et des
années des retards considérables et ce
n'est pas normal que des juges
d'instruction soit confronté à des
capacités de traitement
informatiqu extrêmement limité vous le
voyez qui qui retardent l'efficacité
donc là je dirais dans dans l'exécution
budgétaire des moyens qui n vont nous
être consacrés cré nous serons attentifs
en tout cas le président et les chefs de
juridiction de Paris de de de veiller à
ce que tous les moyens nous soient
donnés et soient bien utilisés voilà
avec un retour aussi sur les
améliorations que nous pourrons
enregistrer mais il reste je crois
définir vraiment des priorités lorsque
nous sommes en responsabilité avec
Madame la procureur de mettre l'accent
aussi sur les violences intrafamiliales
bon ben voilà c'est des procédures en
grand nombre c'est du temps c'est du
temps d'audience en grand nombre ce sont
des capacités de jugement qui sont
prises sur d'autres d'autres audiences
j'insiste aussi sur le fait que même si
souvent l'action judiciaire est vue sous
le spectre pénal et c'est bien légitime
par rapport à l'attente de nos
concitoyens ne jamais perdre de vue
aussi que la justice civile dans toutes
ces déclinaisons et vous le savez
j'imagine avec euh vos administrés dans
les départements constitu aussi une
réalité du quotidien et la justice
civile ne doit pas être marginalisée
elle doit aussi certainement être
revitalisé parce que c'est un enjeu
aussi de cohésion nationale pour les
nombreux justi qui ont des litiges
civils voilà donc il y a matière à être
optimiste par rapport aux objectifs
fixés par le gouvernement et soutenu par
le par par le P nous mettrons tout en
uvre mais il reste encore quand même
aussi des des axes majeurs à
privilégier peut-re madame
Alex prenez votre micro je crois que
Alley Mad
Alex sur
Oui la coordination entre Jun sur les
remontées d'information alors cette
question je dirais euh elle nous
concerne en fait pas tant à
l'instruction peut-être que davantage au
parquet puisque nous en fait on instruit
ce que le parquet a l'honneur de nous
enfin nous confie pardon euh voilà donc
après c'est la coordination oui ce ce
rôle il est plus important du côté du
par il y a des principes qui sont posé
sur lequel à partir de certains seuil ou
d'intérêt d'une affaire les GES ou des
parquets qui sont
infragirs avise en temps réel par
téléphone laagirs de Paris ou la junalco
qu'ils sont saisis d'une affaire pour
que la junalco puisse d'autorité se
saisir de l'affaire donc cette cette
information circule je dirait tout à
fait correctement alors on peut
regretter parfois s'il y a des
exceptions ou des avis qui ont tardé
mais quand même il y a une très bonne
collaboration entre lesgirce et la
junalco pour avoir quand même une
remontée en temps réel c'est-à-dire par
téléphone le jour même pour savoir si
par exemple une garde à vue approche
voire une garde à vue est déjà en cours
la junalco se saisit immédiatement de
l'ffaire donc c'est quelque chose qui
voilà qui marche plutôt bien et qui va
être renforcé également par le
l'application informatique qu'a évoqué
madame Alexi Siroco qui est en fait en
cours de mise en œuvre qui n'est pas
encore totalement
opérationnel euh sur sur l'optimisme
alors même si je vois qu'on aura pas
répondu à une à vos questions monsieur
sénateur
en ce qui concerne pour y revenir moi
c'est un une appellation que je n'aime
pas les mules nous avons l'un et l'autre
été en post à créteille et dans le
territoire de tribunal judiciaire de
créteille il y a Orli où ce sujet des
des mules était é
récurrent je v que c'est c'est assez
tragique lorsqu'on les voit arriver du
territoire et on oscile entre le fait de
les considérer comme victime et comme
auteur c'est c'est une vraie difficulté
les peines c'est celles que vous vous
avez dit enfin en tout cas lorsque nous
étions à créteille des peines en ratio
du kilo et de et de la je dirais de des
antécédents de l'intéresser puisqu'on
faisait des investigations sur est-ce
qu'il avait déjà eu des voyages
récurrents même si elle n'avait jamais
été prises depuis la Guyane jusque
jusqu'au territoire métropolitain
eu les peines à priori sont exécutées
c'est-à-dire sous la réserve des droits
aux réduction de peine que tout à Chac
le droit d'avoir et je dirais même qu'au
niveau de l'application des peines les
juges d'application des peines ne
faisaient pas de différence et essayer
de trouver des modalité de formation
d'intégration ce qui faisait qu'un
certain nombre de personnes d'origine
guyanaise souhaitaent rester sur le
territoire national parce qu'on leur
avait offert des possibilités de
formation qu'elle ne trouvaient
peut-être pas du côté de la Guyane
euh la la le sujet d'importance je crois
que il y a des choses qui doivent
progresser côté guyanais enfin tout ce
qu'on sait a essayé de faire le monsieur
le Préfet localement pour éviter les
embarquements euh sur les destructions
systématiques que vous évoquez dans
d'utres pays je crois qu'il sont en
train d'y revenir un peu qui constatent
que même si c'était une pratique ça n'a
pas forcément été si opérationnel que ça
ça a permis de gérer des flux mais pas
forcément d'interrompre les trafic comme
je l'ai dit hein c'est à un tel niveau
que perdre du produit peut leur importe
et d'ailleurs d'une certaine manière les
mules avec tous les guillemets de que ce
que je mets à cette expression que je
n'aime pas ce sont des trafiquants
sacrifiés deelle manière donc donc voilà
pour la réponse la pis je crois que ça
existe un peu chez nous et j'avoue que
je me suis pas jamais interrogé sur
l'identité numérique mais peut-être
est-ce une bonne piste effectivement à
exploiter tout ce qui permet d'éviter
les faux papiers est évidemment un
progrès sur l'optimisme maintenant
monsieur le Président vous a déjà donné
quelques pistes ben mon optimisme je
crois vous l'avoir dit peut-être en
début de mon propos c'est le fait
d'avoir été convoqué devant vous et de
voir que la représentation parlementaire
et bien s'empare du sujet comme le
gouvernement s'en est emparé l'optimisme
c'est que grâce à ce qu'y CC et et en
crochchat ce qu'on ne connaissait pas
quand on parle d'évolution à chaque fois
je me dis est-ce que ça a évolué ou
est-ce qu'on a été en prise directe avec
la réité de la chose et qu'elle a
toujours été comme ça mais qu'on ne la
connaissait pas euh l'optimisme c'est
que quand même on marque quelques points
l'optimisme c'est qu'on a parce que j'ai
demandé une évolution législative
j'aurais pu laisser penser que le
législateur n'avait pas total était au
rendez-vous de de de cette de cette
action il y a une incrimination que
certains pays nous envie jeis pas dire
beaucoup de pays nous envie mais un
certain nombre c'est celle de la
présomption de blanchiment
elle n'existe pas dans tous les pays
mais je peux vous dire qu'au niveau de
la junalco c'est un outil extrêmement
précieux c'està-dire que c'est tombé sur
quelqu'un il a des des
moyens que facialement il ne peut
expliquer et bien il y a la possibilité
de le poursuivre en déduisant que s'il
n'apporte pas l'explication de ses
revenus on présumera qu'il est blanchi
et ça ça n'existe pas dans tous les
territoires mais c'est un enfin dans
tous les pays mais c'est un outil Éric
si tu veux compléter qui est quand même
très opérationnel et qui est un lieu
d'optimisme par rapport à ce que je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure pardon je parle
plus fort j'ai plus le micro euh du de
ce de ce champ qui reste à investir de
la saisie des avoirs criminels donc il
il faut rester optimiste parce que nous
sommes mobilisés notre rapport oui
simplement oui c'est l'article 32411 du
code pénal qui est une présomption de
manchement qui fait partie de ces
quelques outils qui qui sont assez
nouveaux et qui sont en train de pour
lesquels nous sommes en train de
construire une jurisprudence pour savoir
comment le les juridictions vont réagir
par rapport à la force de ce levier pour
pouvoir faire des saisies et des et des
et des confiscations sur la base de
présomption qui n'ont pas été renversé
par la partie adverse la le dernier mot
revient à notre rapporteur très
brièvement je crois que vous allez nous
adresser des réponses écrites j'aimerais
que elle porte précisément sur deux
sujets l'amélioration des procédures de
saisie nous avons auditionné tracf qui
nous a donné un certain nombre de pistes
nous aimerions avoir là-dessus des
propositions très concrè très précise et
puis pour vous Madame vous avez fait
mention de cette jurisprudence de la
Cour de cassation qui va rendre beaucoup
plus complexe l'instruction des dossier
sur sur la téléphonie et il faudrait
nous adresser un certain nombre de
précisions aussi sur cette jurisprudence
et sur les conséquences de l'application
de cette jurisprudence d'acc de
cassation parce que en face il faudra
sans doute une mesure
législative nous vous remercions
infiniment très chaleureusement pour la
la qualité de ce que vous nous avez dit
votre franchise et puis surtout le
matériau très solide dont nous disposons
pour avancer et on a une liste de cours
si je peux très très très triviale
législative et de moyens qui paraît
utile pour nos futures recommandations
merci
beaucoup on viendra avec
plaisir